In 1971, Ian Waterman suddenly
collapsed from a severe case
of what seemed to be gastric flu.
His illness passed after a few days,
but a stranger set of symptoms lingered.
Although his muscles and joints
remained healthy,
Waterman was unable to move.
In fact, he was unable to feel
anything from the neck down.
Eventually, he was diagnosed with a rare
and extreme form of deafferentation,
a neurological condition
in which certain signals
from the nervous system are
interrupted or impaired.
Without his body's constant feedback
on how his limbs were moving,
Waterman was unable to sit up,
stand, or walk.
But over time, he taught himself
to use sight to judge the distance
of his limbs from other objects.
And eventually he regained
complete control of his body—
so long as he could see it.
We often don’t think of touch
as being a vital part of movement.
But touch is just one part
of the somatosensory system,
a network that oversees all the sensations
arising from the surface and interior
of our bodies.
Touch, pain, temperature,
and our awareness of our bodies in space—
also known as proprioception—
are regulated by this system.
And when something goes wrong,
the effects can be dramatic.
All these sensations are processed
by millions of tiny receptor cells
embedded in our skin, muscles,
tendons, and organs.
Every square centimeter of our skin
is packed with hundreds of these cells,
and their shape, size, and depth determine
what kind of stimuli they respond to.
Mechanoreceptors sense mechanical
deformation of the skin.
This could be triggered by low
or high frequency vibrations,
a stretch,
or simply light, static pressure.
Thermoreceptors respond
to temperature changes,
while nociceptors sense pain.
And propriocepters sit deep
in your muscles and tendons,
continually detecting
and relaying information
about the position of your body.
Your brain then combines this information
with other sensory data
to move through space
without needing to see your limbs.
All of these receptors work by sending
electrical signals to the brain
through fibers they’re attached to.
And the speed of those signals
varies with the fiber’s thickness.
For example, some nociceptors
are attached to fibers
with slightly more conductive,
fatty myelin than others.
So when you get hurt, the electrical
impulses from thicker nociceptors
trigger sharp, intense pain,
while thin, unmyelinated nociceptors
are responsible
for the dull, aching pain that follows.
And since the fibers carrying
tactile information are much thicker
than those carrying nociceptive signals,
rubbing an injury can produce
temporary relief from the pain
These receptors generate
a constant flood of signals
that travel through the nervous system
to the brain.
But if this process is disrupted—
either by damage to the skin,
the nerves, or the brain—
the network breaks down.
And since it underpins so many
bodily functions,
damage to the somatosensory system can
manifest in a wide variety of ways.
In Waterman’s case,
an autoimmune reaction
attacked a large swath
of his nervous system,
leaving him with no tactile
or proprioceptive sensations
from the neck down.
But deafferentation is just one
of many somatosensory disorders.
Individuals can receive damage to a
specific brain area or a section of skin,
resulting in the loss of certain
sensations in particular locations.
And the impact of this loss
can be significant.
Losing tactile sensations makes it
difficult to gauge how much strength
to use in a situation.
Without the warning signals provided
by thermal and pain stimuli,
we don’t react when our
bodies are damaged.
And, being deprived of social touch
can cause a condition
known as touch starvation,
characterized by anxiety, depression,
high blood pressure,
and even a weakened immune system.
Many individuals who face these realities
have found innovative ways to adapt.
But it’s undeniable that all these
invisible sensations
play a vital role
in how we navigate the world—
even if they can be difficult
to put your finger on.